die traurige nachricht vom plötzlichen
tod des präsidenten des europäischen
parlaments
hat uns gestern erreicht
david sasso lee war ein
parlamentspräsident der auf europäischer
ebene genau das konnte
kompromisse schließen das machbare
vorantreiben und das notwendige im blick
behalten die demokratie beweisen mit
david soo lee hat das europaparlament
einen leidenschaftlichen verfechter
europäischer humanitäre werte verloren
auch in schwierigen zeiten stand er
stets für seine überzeugung ein er
vertrat das parlament selbstbewusst
gegenüber dem rat und der kommission
der italienische sozialdemokrat verstand
es auch in seinem hohen amt sich klar zu
positionieren
und dennoch zwischen widerstreitenden
handhaltung und interessen zu vermitteln
zugute kam ihm seine freundliche
verbindliche art
seine in journalismus geschulte
fähigkeit verständlich zu kommunizieren
in strittigen fragen wie der gemeinsame
asyl- und migrationspolitik macht es das
holy immer wieder deutlich dass er auf
der suche nach politischen lösungen das
schicksal einzelner nie verloren gehen
darf
davids hasso lieber ein überzeugter
europäer und ein großer menschenfreund
der deutsche bundestag wird ihm ein
ehrendes andenken bewahren
ich möchte sie bitten sich von ihren
plätzen zu erheben
ich danke ihnen dass sie sich von den
plätzen erhoben haben